[Music]
unable to breastfeed our sick child
Jamia her mother comes to this field
Hospital operated by Doctors Without
Borders
our baby is diagnosed as acutely
malnourished
it started with fever and diarrhea now
we are referred for admission
this is why she and her baby will spend
several weeks recovering
health facilities in and around address
are overstretched and poorly equipped to
deal with such emergency cases
the Border Town hosts more than 400 000
people forced from their homes by
fighting across the border in Sudan
doctors say 20 percent of children in
these camps are severely malnourished
another 20 is moderately affected they
say both the mothers and their babies
suffer from poor nutrition
when this facility in the middle of a
camp opened two months ago 200 acute
malnourished children who are registered
within a week
there are several like it in Eastern
Chad
so now we are catching up on the kids
that are severely mannourished but some
keep coming and some keep being
identified meaning uh the the
malnutrition keep getting worse and uh
and kids are still lacking food the
United Nations warns its Food Supplies
will soon run out
we need to guarantee one meal a day for
all those persons they have really
nothing
but funding is also about to dry up a
concern for doctors and care providers
if there is no more food by the end of
October situation nutrition situation is
going to be terrible for the refugee at
first for the host Community next but
it's the entire Health System that's
gonna suffer from that
if that happens health workers fear the
lives of the mothers and their
malnourished babies they've been trying
to save could be lost how many degrees
Al Jazeera address on the charge Sudan
border
and we can speak now to Ahmed who's
joining us live I was listening to your
report there Ahmed so Food Supplies
running out the un's funding possibly
running out all of this with a late
October deadline really to essentially
save these people where is this all
headed
I think the situation is getting worse
so far
yeah
yeah cereal uh I think I missed the last
part of your question can you repeat
that again no absolutely Ahmed I was we
were all listening to your very
compelling report and you lay out very
clearly what's happening which is that
food supplies are running out that the
un's funding could run out and that some
solution needs to be found by the end of
this month so I was asking you with all
of this
where is this situation headed
Cyril it's uh it's a it's a disaster
waiting to happen unless something
happens in the next few weeks now even
getting funds enough resources like
money
right away may not immediately solve the
problem because when we were talking to
the world food program they were telling
us they have to go to the rural
communities to source for food items
remember a child is also a food insecure
country because of desertification
because of impact of climate change this
country at some point will have to also
depend on external Aid to feed its
communities the lecture you know it is
one of the most fatal areas in the
region in the South and in the western
central Africa region that lake has lost
almost 95 percent of its Waters and the
place is drying up quickly so even if
the United Nations gets all the funding
it needs then definitely it has to look
for food items from various Villages and
these communities these Villages we're
talking about are yet to harvest the
little they have planted over the uh
rainy season so it's a difficult
situation not only for the people on the
ground the refugees of displaced by the
fighting in Sudan but also for the
United Nations trying to help them I
think the the International Community
have has missed a chance of piling up
food items to help these people from the
very beginning because right now
whatever happens in the next few weeks
will definitely have a negative impact
on thousands of people who have been
displaced by this fighting in Sudan and
we're not sure whether or not the influx
of refugees has stopped because they
continue to arrive right that's what I
was about to ask you because we know
more than 400 000 refugees have already
fled the conflict in Sudan over to where
you are in Chad do you still see more
people coming in
exactly Cyril it's it's without doubt
definitely a lot of people will come
this way in fact the Chinese authorities
are estimating that by the end of
December this year we're talking about
three months from now there will be more
than 600 000 refugees from Sudan
entering this country because of the
conflict or the fighting of the past
five months already remember uh the
conflict in Darfur which is more than 20
years old now has displayed another 600
000 refugees who are as scattered in
this particular region some of them are
in camps not far from here some of them
are spread in camps about 100 or 80
kilometers from where we are now so
you're looking at probably 1.2 million
Sudanese refugees who are coming into
child and depending on food Aid that is
no longer available crisis in other
parts of the world have diverted
attention and resources from this crisis
and unfortunately uh poor people who've
been displaced by is conflict in Sudan
will have to pay for it unfortunately
Ahmed Idris reporting from Chad thank
you very much for that reporting